what's the best way to handle awful
random people say a bunch of
intimidating thugs on a bus or a violent
scary drunk person well and there's even
more awful random people out there that
you might need to look out for I think
this is a you know obviously you've got
people that are appointed criminals that
are coming after you you've got
terrorists that might be coming after
you
or just trying to do random acts of mass
violence so those are those are a
particular type I think that this is a
question directed for more of something
that could easily happen yeah to be
right random people that are being jerks
or thugs or people that are drunk or
high or whatever well it's okay so
obviously what do we want to do we want
to be prepared
so to start with you want to be in
really good physical condition
so I mean you want to work out you want
to be ready to handle yourself
physically um you want to know how to
fight that means you need to train
jujitsu boxing Muay Thai wrestling you
if you're in a high crime area you're in
a high threat area and you think this
stuff is really gonna happen out there
then guess what you need to get a
firearm you need to learn how to shoot a
firearm you need to train with the
firearm you need to understand the
ramifications of utilizing a firearm and
then you need to carry it so you can
protect yourself and those same things
go if you decide you're going to carry
any kind of weapon whether it's pepper
spray or a mace or an ASP or a knife
anything that you're gonna carry you
better know what you're doing you need
to prepare with it so that's what you
need to do to be prepared okay
that's yeah that's what in Annie you
don't said this before I set it on the
Sam Harris podcast if you you if you do
these things if you work on your
physical condition if you work on your
fighting if you work on your shooting if
you work on your your weapon skills and
you never have to use them great I I
will still say it has not been wasted
it has been time that has made you a
better person it's been proposed
discipline on you it's gotten you better
physical conditioning it's just good for
you mm-hmm so regardless you should be
training in these type of situations now
once you get to this type of situation
first of all how did you get that
because we need to have situational
awareness right how are you not paying
attention to what's going on around you
you need to pay attention to what's
going on around you and then you watch
for these scenarios that could unfold
and you avoid them period so so how are
you getting stuck on a bus with a bunch
of maniacs right there's something when
they got on you got off that's a real
simple right or you go to get on and you
see these knuckleheads you walk right
back off I mean that's that's pretty
easy and all there's a bunch of
knuckleheads walking down the street
towards you go across the street walk
down the other side situational
awareness oh you hear them coming up
behind you cool
step off across the street avoid we want
to be have situational awareness that's
gonna solve that should solve 99% of
your problems is being aware of your
surroundings understanding your
situation planning what about just
simple planning like where you going
when are you gonna come home you know if
you took a subway into the city at night
and you know you're gonna coming home
late at night and you're alone and you
are suspect of what's happening maybe
you get an uber instead of ride in the
subway
it's just planning that comes into play
as well to avoid these situations now if
you do get caught in these situations
here's a couple recommendations okay my
number one is to kind of do your best to
detach from from this scenario right so
you got let's say you're on a bus and
there's a bunch of people acting crazy
and they jumped on right after you got
on and you couldn't get off in time so
now you're on the bus with them I want
you to detach from them so that means
you're not looking at them you're not
staring at them you're not being all
intimidated you want to just attach just
do what you would normally do you know
everyone carries a phone these days
break out your phone start looking at
your phone pull out your paper start
looking at your paper study if you don't
have either one of those two you know
look outside look at the passing just
just don't enter their world
don't become a part of their thing that
they have going on because what they
want to do is they want you to make eye
contact what they want you is glance
over at them what they want you to do is
enter their world because a lot of times
these knuckleheads that they're in their
own world and you actually have to
penetrate their world if you want to get
in there so what you want so what I'm
gonna do is I'm just gonna remain I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna cower though
there's a difference okay because if you
give the impression of you're just like
cowering and scared well then there
that's that's entering their world and
they're they're gonna recognize that but
if you just hey sitting here just doing
what you'd normally doing it's not a big
deal you do this all the time you don't
care about them don't care about me
leave me alone that's that's where I'm
going now if for whatever reason I make
some kind of eye contact right now I
made the eye contact
I've entered their world I'm gonna go
ahead give it a little head nod you know
just a little just a little regular head
nod like I would do with you if I saw
you on the street hey you know just a
little respectful little head nod and
then I'm gonna go right back to what I
was doing to go right back out of the
world I acknowledge their world I'm not
gonna give a bunch of I'm not gonna look
scared but I'm not gonna look aggressive
I'm just gonna be respectful a little
head nod you know hope you having a good
night
um and then go go back to your business
again I just want to detach from them
that's my attitude isn't wanted attached
for them and this avoids them saying you
know like if they're looking at you and
you don't look back or or they're just
like bearing down on you hey hey why
aren't you why you ignoring me or
whatever you too cool for me or
something like that so sometimes you
look a little head nod it's all good
if if now if they do start now see I'm
escalating this so they're escalating it
so now if they do start to escalate this
thing in like like you know were you
looking at or one of those things it's
just again what you're trying to do is
you're trying to de-escalate without
being appearing one more
you know so maybe it's just you know hey
no issue here you know just something
simple like that no I'm good
like what are you doing just riding the
bus home you know what I mean just real
matter-of-fact just didn't go try and
get back but you know we might want to
just even try and and and connect a
little connection instead of I'm trying
to go home cuz that's my pissed some
people off cuz I don't have a home or
their home is a bad place so what might
be better than saying that is you know I
just got done with work
now you're just a working man right of
course you might be dealing with some of
that doesn't have a job and lost their
jobs so I'm saying you're not gonna come
up with a grip but my point here is just
you're just gonna try and make simple
non confrontational statements that
don't give them anything to grab on to
because that's what they want they want
something they they just want something
to grab on to you know that's what
they're looking for so you don't want to
let that happen now things can still
continue to escalate
you know you get someone that's
determined to be a jerk or determined to
be hostile return be aggressive now I'll
tell you that if you train then you work
out and you do jujitsu and you have
skills people know it people people that
are belligerents generally can tell even
in a drunken state when you square off
with someone or you look at someone and
they have an attitude of like look I do
this all the time I'm good you want to
fight I'm here not saying that but just
a little bit and you can tell yeah if
they're real troublemakers they can tell
now sometimes that's not a good thing
because that means they're gonna do the
challenge you know so you got to watch
out for that so I think that that's
right even though on the internet it
might tell it it might seem like it's
telling a different story you know it's
like oh guy confronts the wrong guy you
know guy street thug confronts jujitsu
master or something and it shows that
they actually fought so it kind of seems
like oh no they don't know obviously out
there know they but that's
air man and that's why it makes the
internet so it's rare typically yeah and
this is no guarantee but I understand
I could tell even before I started doing
jiu-jitsu you know I could tell if
somebody was ready to rhumble is like I
was ready to rumble no fight training to
a guy who was belligerent to me directly
right Terry was there we were working
and all I did was act like I knew yeah I
didn't know by the way act like I knew
and in front of everybody guy was like
oh hey I'm sorry man it's my bad I
believed a little bit bigger than me too
and he just said but I was ready to I
was ready to do the best fighting I
could because it was it was kind of go
time at that point yeah he was like you
know the kind guy where he's talking
he's like yeah man I'm from Chicago and
he's like rubbing against me in my face
kind not like I want to fight you but
just like like almost like a dog would
you know and rubbing against me and then
whatever you know I made like okay we're
about to fight took on my jacket real
quick or whatever and um and was like
all right mmm like just go just like her
you're saying no just real matter calm
real man oh yeah you do this all the
time yep and the thing I understand that
it is on right now understand and then
the guy in heat surprisingly it's not
like Prosser hey my bad my bad bro my
dad it's not surprising because people
that act like that are weak and they're
insecure and they're acting on that and
so when somebody stands up to them and
they look at him and think this guy
might actually know how to fight yeah
then that's what happens and by the way
when you do train all the time you do
know how to fight and then as a matter
of fact you're like yeah I'll fight you
yeah hold on yeah well it's it's a good
feeling to know that you can handle
yourself now okay so now this is this
continues to escalate and you know if
you just try and keep your distance from
people you don't want to let them get
close you don't know they got a knife
you don't know what kind of disease they
you just want to keep away from you know
but eventually you might not be able to
back up anymore you might not be able to
keep any distance watch their hands keep
as much distance you can eventually you
got to put your hands up in kind of a
non-confrontational way to protect your
face to protect the sucker punch that's
coming you know you put your hands up
just in a non-confrontational way up up
around your head
and continue to deescalate hey man I'm
not here
don't don't want any problems mmm you
know I'm not looking for an issue I
don't know what your issue is but I
don't have any issue with you I'm just
trying to head home from work you know
one of those things and finally if you
get to a point where you have no choice
well then you utilize the skills that
you have you hit hard to hit fast you
don't stop hiding until the threat is
neutralized and then you get away and
that's in order to be able to do that
you know go to step 1 prepare yeah
that's um you're the 99% of situations
will be avoided if you're just aware
most of that most important thing yeah
that's a huge deal so true yeah we would
much rather have you do that because any
of these situations I could go out I'm
pretty well prepared for anything I
could go out tonight and have some guys
square off with me and as I'm getting
ready to fight him so his buddy cracks
me in the head with a with a bottle and
kills me that could happen tonight yeah
that could happen at a restaurant
tonight that could happen yeah so what
am I gonna try and do try to avoid it
the minute you square off with somebody
you're now you're now a target for all
his friends by the way I've been in some
bar fights where the idiot
that is being belligerent doesn't have
the common sense or doesn't have the
sense that he's surrounded yeah yeah by
you know by my friends you know and
you're just thinking
you don't even you're doomed yeah so
luckily the guys that I hang out with
are pretty honorable people that aren't
just gonna you know crush somebody's
skull but you don't always give that's
no guarantee that's no guarantee there's
murders every day in America and they're
not planned all of them seldom are they
planned it's done a Facebook I think I
always get confused with the name
because like a lot of people will be
like hey echoes you know and ask me
questions in this podcast so as well as
the other podcast this podcast I don't
want to be like okay he asked me but no
it was yeah
anyway so a guy asked me like this
scenario was used at a bar or party or
something and and guys were being
disrespectful to him and his wife or a
girlfriend or something and then he's
like I know the high road I know the
right thing to do quote-unquote is to to
be done with it you know to leave the
situation but when you leave you feel
like a little you know like you wussed
out and that's really powerful feeling
that you don't want so like what do you
do man how do you just how do you
reconcile late or should I fire under
certain circumstance for the honor kind
of thing like what's the thing and so
I've always really looked at it this way
especially if you're kind of like if you
have mental can kind of control over the
situation where you can be like okay am
I gonna fight this guy or what so when
you choose to engage you wanna fight the
guy you know what you said the wrong
thing to me and I'm gonna square off for
it to my life or whatever you know so
I'm gonna choose to square off now all
you did use you took on all the
potential results of that you took all
that on even if you win the fight you
get arrested like everything as opposed
to taking on all the potential results
probable you know it would that come
with not engaging which include going
home safe your wife safe everybody safe
wake up tomorrow just like you would the
other day and then compare that to jail
I'm injured in some way I can't you know
I can function less tomorrow if I didn't
make it home tomorrow you know death all
this stuff when you kind of consider the
outcomes that you want and the reason
you're gonna make one decision over the
other it kind of it comes real clear
even though at the time it's so powerful
because you're like oh man I don't know
what's out in front of everybody or my
wife you know it's my honor in front of
my wife bye your wife wants you to leave
or fight whoo-hoo like I'm so proud of
him you know know your kids are like I'm
glad you're home dad ya know that's
another thing that comes with I think
with training all the time is we all
know where we stand
yeah like I mean if the if there's a
person that's gonna beat me in a bar
fight I know him like he it's a famous
fighter it's a famous jiu-jitsu player
it's someone that is a known public
figure that
is known for flighty that's like who's
gonna give if it's a civilian that
doesn't train I mean they don't they're
not gonna stand a chance now if for the
French Open of course you're not some
issues well but yes yes the the best
thing to do is avoid but does your wife
when your wife knows that you train
every day that you get after it every
day that you're physically fit
physically strong and knows that you
could destroy that person does she look
down on you when you walk out of there
no she's like well I'm glad I married an
actual man instead of an idiot right and
it's not did that big overdue like hey
bro if you want to fight here come to
this gym I'll be there tomorrow at ten
o'clock
yeah it's will go yeah I'm not gonna
fight out here and get arrested man
you're in sued by you after you're after
I put you to sleep and then I make it so
you can't use your arms anymore yes
forever yes and even that I mean really
let's really admit it even doing that
like hey you want to fight I do want to
fight you right but I you know I'm a
smart fighter so even that that's like
exactly as far as moves go
although hey look I'm not if someone
does that and post it on the internet or
something like that or come on let's
face it we don't want to see that a part
of us wants to see that
yeah you see the bully get beat up yeah
but really at the end of the day that's
not the decision the decision is it
you're right because it goes back when I
said that earlier question if you're
secure in your manhood
yeah then it's not that big of a deal to
go dude you're drunk and carry on I'm
out of here with my wife we're gonna go
back to a house and carry on with our
lives like normal people yeah you can
find another person to get in a drunk
fight with and end up in jail let me ask
you this you can be honest even as a
full-grown secure man if you found
yourself in that scenario and you're
like not me and my wife we're gonna go
home there's still a small party of
course oh well especially when you enjoy
fighting yeah I mean fighting that's fun
and actually you know one of the guys at
the gym who's uh brown belt Mike
he hasn't trained much when you're there
anyways yeah Mike yeah dude he's usually
goes in the morning yeah he's usually
there anyway anyways um he had somebody
like say something to know somebody
somebody like smacked his girlfriend's
ass like what like he brought his
girlfriend into the bar yeah and he does
more Thai of course and he's a badass
dude he walks in the bar and this guy
just straight-up just BAM slaps his
girlfriend's ass and he like turned
around boom one two to the head dropped
the guy knee to the face out I was like
yep
boom got arrested he paid eight thousand
dollars or something and did like 72
hours in jail I mean it was it was legit
like any and he and he talks about it I
mean just to show you like it
differently and that's why like his
attitude you know I talked about he's
like yeah you know the guy crossed the
line and I had to put him down
yeah it was like yeah okay yeah and
that's that's an awesome story by the
way it gives me like a real like but
yeah but let's face it though that
wasn't the right move as far as before
you do it yeah I mean it you're right
because we don't know what could have
happened yes we don't we know what the
actual outcome was and it it was like
eight thousand dollars you know and his
wife girlfriend girlfriend okay just his
girlfriend don't mess with Mike's girl
man well I'm just saying if you have a
wife and then on top of it if you have
like a kids the $8,000 oh it seems more
detrimental yeah that's true
but you know so I'm saying this is why
you treat people with respect yeah you
know because otherwise you never know
who you're messing with
and Mike doesn't look like he's a big
intimidating guy by any chance what does
he weigh 170 I'm thinking of a different
guy I realize it but what Mike's 170
he's tough it he's a tough bastard too I
mean on the mat he's tough but he's like
170 and you know what he's a brown belt
in jujitsu really good with Aggie and he
wrestled like he dressed in high school
so yeah a nice any train more time so
he's just a tough dude yeah and you
don't know who you're messing with
and boom but the interesting thing is
and you know this I know this when you
make eye contact with another person in
a
like that you already know if they train
or not you're like oh this guy trains
for sure I'm in for it you know this is
gonna be it's gonna be on you know
that's awareness from the training yep
but still awesome story don't do that
yeah yeah I know don't do what Mike did
yeah but Mike keep it up no Mike don't
do it again yeah don't mess with Mike's
girl